despite a recent surge of mass shootings
the world's biggest gun lobby is more
defiant than ever NRA members fight like
hell for freedom and get more of it and
win over and over and over again just
weeks after a school shooting in
Nashville and days after a Louisville
workplace Massacre the National Rifle
Association is holding its annual
conference with speeches by every major
Contender for the 2024 Republican
Presidential nomination we saved our
Second Amendment and we're going to save
it for a long time to come it's under
siege but we're going to save it for a
long time to come forever but we don't
need gun control
we need Crime Control outside a dozen or
so protesters including two graduates of
Michigan State University site of a mass
shooting in February called for a ban on
assault rifles the weapon of choice of
mass Shooters I think there's no reason
for them it I really would love to get
rid of all of them proliferation of guns
is just outrageous the NRA has fallen on
Hard Times in recent years it's lost a
million of what was 5 million members in
2018 and it's being sued by the New York
State Attorney General for violating
state laws with lavish spending on its
leaders after successfully pushing as a
senator for a ban on assault weapons
that expired in 2004 President Biden has
called for that ban to be renewed banned
assault weapons now
ban them now
once and for all
but that's not likely to happen in a
divided Congress where the NRA's
influence remains strong enough to block
any major changes in U.S gun laws on the
state level legislatures are actually
easing gun laws last year Indiana joined
21 other states in eliminating permits
allowing gun owners to carry their
weapons in public without certification
or a background check leaving more guns
on the street in a nation that already
has more of them than any other John
hendren Al Jazeera Indianapolis